this year's Independence Day
celebrations looked a little different
due to the Cova 19 pandemic but that
didn't stop plenty of people from
heading out the door to watch our local
firework shows or co-manage oins us live
now from Green Valley Ranch Resort
Casino & Spa with more on the
festivities there hey there or go either
Sasha happy fourth of July to all our
viewers the party here at Green Valley
Ranch has officially wrapped up but
earlier tonight this empty parking lot
I'm in right now was packed with cars
many family is deciding to watch the
fireworks here's part of the show the
fireworks display lasted less than 10
minutes with fireworks lighting up the
night sky many families from across the
area parked across the street from Green
Valley Ranch to watch the display most
of the groups we saw were socially
distancing themselves from each other
and while some people were wearing masks
plenty of people were not despite being
in the midst of the Cova 19 pandemic and
they're being live streams available to
watch the fireworks shows people we
spoke with say they made sure to take
the proper precautions so they could see
the fireworks in person because we've
been locked down for so long
and it's just nice to get out and do
something quote-unquote normal for a
while we figured we could be here and
stay in by our vehicle and be able to
watch some good fireworks i'm the
chroman irish in this instruction is
over we also captured video of this some
people deciding to put on their own
firework shows across the valley of
course these are not safe in st.
fireworks so they're not allowed but it
definitely made for an interesting sight
so how is the turnout tonight we talked
to folks who have been here before at
Green Valley Ranch for the 4th of July
fireworks and they say the crowds were
pretty much the same as in prior years
reporting live in Henderson tonight Orko
mana 8 News now